will federal student loan payments have
been paused until august 31st yes and
while borrowers haven't been required to
make payments for more than two years
one expert tells us how nevada borrowers
can budget for student loan payments
during this time of inflation
the time for borrowers to resume paying
their federal student loans is
approaching as the u.s department of
education's paws on federal student
loans set to expire in september but
with rising prices of food housing gas
and more borrowers need to be factoring
student loan payments into their budget
now rather than later honest to goodness
next to rent mortgage this is probably
your biggest payment mary joe terry is a
student loan payment expert with y refi
in nevada alone borrowers have racked up
11 billion dollars in student loans with
the average debt per borrower about
thirty three thousand dollars she says
now is the time to assess your loan
situation a lot of people that have
federal loans also have private loans so
take a few minutes and actually see
how much you owe are you in a variable
or fixed interest rate
and think about where you can kind of
crunch those that money and while
there's been conversation on pushing the
repayment out until december and that a
portion of certain qualifying loans
might be forgiven there are no absolutes
at this point use this time to make sure
your loan is in good standing start
making some payments on that loan to set
yourself up for success every dollar
that you make a payment right now goes
towards the principal balance of your
loan i know a number of individuals that
have just started putting money away at
least i have the money sitting aside so
that when we do go into repayment maybe
i can make a big
principal payment and it will come
directly off your principal balance by
saying hey i've got a couple thousand
dollars here and that's going to make a
significant difference
she adds you might also qualify for a
discount if your loan is placed on auto
debit and there are some forgiveness
programs available to apply for head to
studentaid.gov to apply